expectations
our tricky things hypeeeee it's a tricky
thing you know people freak out about
stuff and we live in at a time in a day
and age where the common dialect is very
much rooted in superlatives you know you
notice that everything around is sort of
described as being either the greatest
or the worst [ __ ] term so in order to
cope with this because you know people
are freaking out about stuff all the
time
in order to cope with this I have kind
of adjusted my approach to movies
because movies are arguably the most
popular art form we all engage in and
they're the most sort of subject to the
effects of hype and expectation so when
going into most movies I try to manage
my expectations I try not to watch too
much stuff you know too many trailers
too many this or that because you know I
want to enjoy going to the movies and I
want to be as fresh as possible you know
I don't want to paint too much of a
picture for myself before I go in so I
try to keep things managed I try to not
let myself get too extraordinarily
excited for things which is kind of a
bummer you know because what you want to
be excited about everything but you know
in the current damage we live in there's
so much stuff around it's hard to get
excited about everything it's hard to
you know yeah so there are two movies I
can think of in recent memory that I
personally allowed myself to get excited
for as much as I damn well pleased
there are two movies that I didn't try
to manage or hamper any my expectations
bring them closer earth one was worlds
end.the Simon Pegg Nick Frost Edgar
Wright film a couple years ago I decided
I'm gonna take that one because I trust
those guys I'm gonna allow myself to be
as excited as I wanted to be and it was
great like I love
that movie I had a great time it
satisfied my expectations and that was
such a joy because a lot of times now
it's hard to do that and the second
movie I can think of where I allowed
myself to get as excited as I just
naturally want it to be was this man was
Mad Max fury road I've seen the first
two films I admit I haven't seen Mad Max
Beyond Thunderdome yet I will see it but
I like the Mad Max world I like Mad Max
a lot and I saw the trailer for this and
I was like holy [ __ ] this could be the
one this could be something special and
I allowed myself to get excited for this
movie and
I'm just so I'm just so happy um you
know man
I don't know quite where to begin so I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna say this now I
think the rest of Hollywood you know the
rest of the people making these big
expensive noisy action movies on to sit
down and take a couple pointers from
George Miller and company because Mad
Max fury road at least is right now I
all my goodness I haven't had this
experience in a movie a long long time
there were five applause breaks you know
what to say about this movie I mean you
can already probably tell how I'm
feeling this movie is like the other Mad
Max movies a force of nature you know
it's a force of nature and and mettle
and you know those movies arguably very
but you know the first one is good in
the second one I love road warrior let's
let's just get into this right now oh
man this movie uh I'm a little lost for
words this this movies is kind of a
symphony in a way and it really is
because it has these movements and it
has these these passages it is sort of a
symphony of destruction and fire and
heat and sand and metal and hope and
lack of hope and violet like it is kind
of beautiful in a really harsh way it's
a force of nature and so few movies are
now so few movies are allowed to be that
and I so appreciate this I haven't been
this enthralled by an action movie in a
long time I haven't felt this way after
an action movie in a long
time I went with some friends they
graciously bought me a ticket and
returned for a favor and and we went you
know with all the bells and whistles and
after the movie we just sort of sat
there like the theater was clearing out
and we were just sitting there just kind
of piecing our brains back together
because this movie is a force of nature
and in so few movies nowadays R&I that's
off the bat that is something I so
admire because you don't see stuff like
this a lot this this is something
special even if you don't like it I
would argue this is something that is
special and it does carry on the spirit
of the original Mad Max films and it
adds to it and it even brings a certain
progressive quality to it it's not
in-your-face necessarily it's not like
look the message but in a way that's
almost even more powerful you have this
this very real but very simple struggle
you know you start in this futuristic
knee allistic just nasty dystopian
future these people are basically
worshiping this this guy in Morton Joe
who lives in this big rock tower and he
is the only one with access to water
because water things like water and
gasoline and and even just anything
green or woefully scarce in this version
of the world and so we start out on max
Max Rockatansky and he's alone you know
but not for long because things kick off
pretty much right away he's being
pursued by these you know insane
futuristic dudes and he's on the run and
and pretty quickly catch him and then
the main action that sort of kicks off
the main plot of the film comes when on
a sort of routine gasoline and and
bullet run Imperator furiosa Charlize
Theron takes a bit of a detour she's got
a different plan and that sort of where
things kick off chaos and mayhem ensue
and this movie you know we get a lot of
spectacle now you know spectacle isn't
that special anymore because spectacle
is everywhere like look at this summer
summer 2015 is shocker box full of big
loud effects driven extravaganzas and
this is a big loud extravaganza but
there's a fundamental approach this
movie takes to that that I think
separates it from a lot of other movies
coming out right now the approach that
this movie takes just to its action
because action is its language you know
the language of these movies is
destruction and gasoline and revving
engines and stuff like that and just to
know that a lot of this stuff is there
somehow you know and then aided by CG
when it needs to be makes it all the
more visceral and it gives it that much
more of punch it makes it that much more
palpable and that's how I think and a
lot of people think you know you should
approach effects now is sort of what can
we do in camera let's do that and then
what can't we do in camera then we'll
bring in the CG Mary CGI and practical
effects together and you get something
like this it's hard to direct good
action you know we get a lot of actions
some of its better than others and this
is top notch man the action is is
spectacular in but but for real it's a
lean story you know it's it's it's a
relatively simple story but it's told in
such a way were you and even if you
haven't seen the other films you can get
what kind of world you're in what the
details of this world are because there
is so much on screen you know there's a
lot of visual storytelling and stuff
like that the plot of this movie is
pretty simple it's a chase movie you
know it's very immediate things happen
things go wrong there are a lot of
forces at odds and that's where a lot of
the main action comes from you know and
it's it is simple and it is
straightforward in that way and the
dialogue is very sparing but it does
that really well you know it's like
events unfold and they all kind of abide
by the rules of this world there isn't a
whole lot of like well that was
convenient you know and every victory
victory victory no victory comes without
a very difficult fight you know every
victory this movie gets and and every
tragedy as well has an impact and you
feel the cost of it all and you feel the
weight of it all you're compelled by the
action because it's just so huge and
it's overwhelming almost and it's to use
the word for its actual purpose it's
awesome
with the approach and care that comes
with you know choreographing these
chases and these acrobatic sequences and
really making you know action not just
cool but beautiful and creative and
hypnotic you know like they really put
these things on scream your jaws on the
floor a little better at least mine ones
and then when there are moments in
between where people were talking or
figuring out the next move you'll listen
up because there aren't a lot of words
to pick from you know and I think that
this movie establishes a really cool
contrast that way the performance is
really good too you know Charlize Theron
and Tom Hardy Nicholas Hoult everyone
you know just feels like they're living
in and are from this world and you know
max spends so much time in this movie as
he has in the other movies being you
don't get to know a lot about max you
know he's not inclined to tell anybody
about himself you know he's this is a
world in which you don't make a lot of
connections but it still works you can
still see the history in his face and in
charlize theron face and in everyone
like everyone in this movie does a
really good job and this is a movie you
know whose story is all kind of told in
the action not necessarily even set
pieces and whatnot but you know this is
a world that isn't very diplomatic it's
not a world where people talk a whole
lot you know it's just the necessity for
speech this isn't a civilized society
they're living in so so much of the you
know stuff that happens in this movie is
visual and immediate but the actors all
do a really good job you know sort of
inhabiting this world and the world
itself I mean just the designs of
everything and
you know just this vision you know I
really appreciate what George Miller is
doing here I mean George Miller created
this you know back at the end of the 70s
in the 70s and the 80s to to it to a
different degree the 70s was a time
where like movies did still have this
sort of anything could happen force of
nature quality and this really brings
that spirit back full throttle pardon
the pun this is one of those movies
where for me all the technical stuff
kind of comes together to make a really
cohesive whole all the performances are
on point you really believe you know
these people inhabit this harsh version
of the world and you know the direction
is strong and confident I mean George
Miller has been doing this for a very
long time and it shows man I mean every
article feels the need to point out just
how seven-d George Miller is you know
sometimes a lot of directors you know
you lose your touch but this guy doesn't
seem like he's lost anything I mean it's
a very confidently directed movie it's a
confidently paced movie the
cinematography is incredible and I know
they made a conscious decision with the
colors in this film because so many of
the sort of post-apocalyptic landscapes
we get now are all washed out or D
saturated and they wanted to play with
colors and this and you get very
distinct colors you know there's a lot
of this movie is really red and orange
and stuff like that and during the
nighttime shots you know they went with
day for night to create this really blue
this rich blue tone for the nighttime
scenes and any flash of green you know
all the colors really pop in this movie
and they make everything seem in a way
you know even more hot and desolate and
and oppressive you know it's like
there's so much color that almost feels
like it's swallowing you up and almost
makes all that heat and dust palpable
and the music you know junkie XL did a
lot of music for this and the score ties
in really great and the score is really
diverse because there's some stuff
that's electronic you know some stuff
that is really intense and droning and
deep and there's some stuff that you
know harkens to classical music you know
that that is very expressive and not
making mousy but like you know
expressive with
you know movements and you know natural
instruments and even some like coral
stuff and it really complements
everything really well you know so it's
like when you get everything together
when you get this immediate story and
these actors you know you get George
Miller's vision along with the paintin
like the editing and the cinematography
and just the visual look the designs you
know the details of the world the music
you know and you know combine all that
with the action and and the acrobatics
and all this crazy stuff I mean it is
really spectacular behold if we don't
get movies like this anymore very often
now that are sort of populated by these
really strange characters where you feel
like just about anything can happen you
know it's a harsh nihilistic world but
you see where it came from you know it's
like men are reduced to their basest
instincts and that's where the more
feminist undertones of this movie get
really cool because you know Imperator
furiosa and her team like they're
they're looking for something different
you know and I'm not gonna spoil
anything but they're there there is
something different you know to be had
and that's just cool and it all makes
sense because you know a lot of people
are also freaking out about the feminist
aspect of this movie and they shouldn't
be because a I mean equality is good and
be the things that do embody the
feminist undertones in this movie it's
like part of what makes those all the
better and all the more powerful and and
really applause were they are the fact
that the movie itself doesn't call
attention to them and be like look what
we're doing it's an important thing but
the movie just incorporates it into its
story it's just how it's going that's
just the fight it's just people and and
what they're fighting for you know and
and you know the stakes that they all
have to come to grips with not whether a
man or a woman is doing certain things
it just so happens that there is a
strong female presence in the movie and
there is sort of a subtle contrast
between the prominent female characters
that show up in this movie and the
roided-out juiced-up gearhead you know
savage war clan that's coming after them
and it seems just like a movie that was
made with a lot of thought and a lot of
care and that is so precious now it
seems like they waited to the right time
and they had the right people the right
approach the
right idea and this movie to me deserves
every ounce of praise it gets I I wanted
to see it again immediately I can't wait
to the next time I get to watch this
movie I really liked it and my hats off
to them too George Miller and everybody
who was involved you know if you're
looking for nitpick Snee ADR could have
been better but really in an environment
like that when you're shooting out and
you know the desert I gotta imagine
getting good set sound is really hard so
Mad Max fury road man I can't recommend
this movie enough and I really hope
everybody enjoys it I'm not trying to be
like good but I am being like oh my god
but you know I am so enthralled I'm so
happy because this is just a breath of
fresh air in terms of the approach you
know George Miller owns the rights to
this and it seems like that's a good
thing because they made a bunch of
really wise decisions and this movie
stands apart from a lot of the things we
get nowadays so I'm feeling as if you
couldn't tell I'm feeling very positive
on this get to the theater you know
support this I think this is a movie
worth supporting so um yeah man
everything about this I I really dug I
was so pleased you know like I said
there are five five applause breaks
during this in the in screening a so
that's how you do it man that's that's
how you do a crazy apocalypse movie and
I'm just so happy that a movie could
make me feel like this again now you
know and so hats off to everybody
involved
- George Miller to the cast to the crew
you know everybody involved in making
this movie it's it's it's a real treat
and I think it's fantastic I'm just
really happy they pulled it off man
because for me they pulled it off with
flying colors a plus thumb up whatever
you want to give it but get thee to the
theater pensee Mad Max fury road pay for
it see it on the biggest screen you can
I imagine your head might explode but
see it in 3d if you have to but get thee
to this movie because it really is
something special especially now and it
was a nice reminder of what action
cinema can be I loved it I loved it so
you know
forgive me for feeding the hype machine
but it didn't [ __ ] it up for me so
hopefully it won't [ __ ] it up for you
see ya Mad Max fury road is the film
Jerry is my name let's talk about this
what would you guys like to see more of
or or see a return tour to see in
general you know for action cinema or
for you know post-apocalyptic cinema now
what's something you'd like to see maybe
return to form or just in general let's
talk about that anyhow Mad Max fury road
is the film I am Jerry Cheers